hey guys I'm just McDonald here with
another GS news update and let's talk
about getting your hands on the future
today well not today but soon Sony's
getting into virtual reality let's get
into it PlayStation are getting into the
VR realm with their new initiative
project Morpheus though they have noted
that it is by no means the final
prototype head mounted display was
unveiled at a GDC presentation today and
Sony president Shuhei Yoshida has said
that nothing elevates the level of
emotion better than VR Sony hope the
initiative will push the games industry
forward and has spent the last three
years working to prototype and evolve
virtual reality tech obviously this one
will come on to the market to compete
with the oculus rift and the device
rumored to be coming forward from
Microsoft dr. Richard Marx of Sony's R&D
department has said that virtual reality
is set to become the preferred medium
and will push beyond gaming and into the
industries although this will only come
about if virtual reality is
exceptionally easy to use sony also
commented on the issue of motion
sickness saying that head motion is lure
when approaching VR experiences at this
point in time project Morpheus comes
with a 1080p display a high frame rate
clean rendered images and 3d audio and
we'll work with online and local couch
multiplayer Epic Games unity Crytek and
autodesk are among Sony's first partners
on the project Sony's GDC brute will
feature playable demos that include a
reworking of Square Enix of sleeves and
Eve Valkyrie will it be awesome or awful
let me know what you reckon in the
comments and be sure to check back to
gamespot for more on project Morpheus
and everything virtual reality